[Música]
la organización de naciones unidas para
la agricultura y la alimentación y el
programa mundial de los alimentos
advirtieron que existe el riesgo de que
haya una crisis alimentaria generalizada
ya que el hambre amenaza la estabilidad
en decenas de países de acuerdo con las
organizaciones la situación en ucrania
desató una ola de hambre colateral
generando una crisis alimentaria global
donde la república democrática del congo
haití la región del sahel sudan y siria
continúan siendo los países de gran
preocupación con condiciones críticas en
deterioro asimismo un informe presentado
por ambos organismos internacionales
acerca de los puntos críticos de hambre
de mayo 2022 señala acciones como
etiopía nigeria sudán del sur y yemen en
permanente alerta máxima como puntos
críticos con condiciones catastróficas
este es el panorama entonces sobre todo
en áfrica para ello quiero saludar a
nuestro segundo invitado al día de
abraham él es el responsable de lines
ellas perdón ella es la responsable de
la incidencia para el sahel de la acción
contra el hambre gracias a por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
n le pregunta entonces el panorama
general de la crisis alimentaria
buenas tardes y gracias por la ya por la
invitación
bueno como venía diciendo no la estamos
enfrentados a una crisis alimentaria muy
importante en todo el mundo pero
especialmente en áfrica haciendo énfasis
en el sahel llevamos varios años viendo
una tendencia muy preocupante estamos
ahora con cifras que se acercan a las
grandes
crisis alimentarias de los micro teques
que ha sido la más la que ha sido muy
importante y la que ha golpeado la
región de manera muy importante ahora
estamos con las mismas cifras entonces
llevamos tres años viendo un cúmulo de
una nombre de inseguridad alimentaria
muy importante ahora estamos viendo como
en
2022 en esos meses que están empezando
el mes que junio agosto de septiembre 40
millones de personas se van a enfrentar
solo en la región de áfrica en el oeste
40 millones de personas se van a
enfrentar a una situación porque no
pueden cubrir sus necesidades
alimentarias
perdón que interrumpa eso también por
supuesto va a aunado al cambio climático
las sequías las inundaciones
los huracanes también y los ciclones que
diezman la agricultura y la ganadería
provocando los expresamente los
desplazamientos de la población también
el cambio climático es un factor
determinante para esta inseguridad
alimentaria
efectivamente son zonas donde hay
grandes retos estructurales para empezar
pobreza crónica acceso a los servicios
básicos muy muy muy bajos entonces
estamos conversando con anima habrá
responsable de incidencia para el saber
en acción contra el hambre
mena gracias gracias por por continuar
con nosotros decayó hay la señal y un
momento pero ya ya la retomamos entonces
estamos hablando sobre la incidencia del
cambio climático en esta inseguridad
alimentaria
efectivamente y como le decía no el tema
de la armada hay factores agravantes que
son importantes uno es el cambio
climático como decía estamos bien en la
región del sahel como la sequía pero
también las inundaciones están afectando
un montón una de las de los de los
factores que estamos viendo por ejemplo
en el caso de níger es que tenemos casi
el 40% de la producción agrícola ha
caído este año eso es un es un es un
dato muy muy importante por otro lado
también tenemos que ver que hay otros
factores importantes como lo que es el
conflicto y la inseguridad en la zona
especialmente en el sahel esto hace que
el número de desplazados está allá en
agua en algunos países se ha triplicado
en los últimos dos años tenemos datos
también de personas que quiero poder
acceder a los a sus cultivos entonces
esos son medios de vida que están muy
afectados servicios básicos a la salud
al agua y también muy a afectarse
entonces un panorama
muy complicado y también todavía estamos
montándolo los efectos de the hobbit que
todavía siguen ahí entonces que sea en
los gol los precios de los alimentos
también en los precios también el acceso
a los servicios por ejemplo un y salud
que siguiéndome afectados después del
impacto úrico y entonces todavía no nos
habíamos recuperado del joven ahora no
le hemos visto el último tiempo de
cambio climático el conflicto y ahora
claro también ahora con la situación con
el conflicto
y de rusia también son países con una
alta dependencia de importación para la
alimentación además no te veo que es el
impacto sobre él
el petróleo la el aceite todo eso está
afectando mucho estos países por ejemplo
en guaraní depende 50% de unir sus
importaciones de cereales depende de
rusia en este caso estamos en
situaciones muy problemáticas entonces
realmente es una situación que sí que
nos hace pensar nos fuerzan a pensar
ver más allá de lo que es la situación
inmediata es verdad que es una situación
de una crisis alimentaria
tenemos que salvar vidas y tenemos que
movilizarnos y eso son donde cada año
ven a que la lente romper para decir
cómo podemos salvar esas vidas como se
puede digamos solventar esta crisis tan
tremenda que están sufriendo las
personas en áfrica y también en la
región del sahel
efectivamente hay dos vías la primera y
la más inmediata es salvar vidas ahora
mismo eso significa financiar la crisis
financiar con primero con acción
temprano ahora mismo estamos llegando
tarde a la acción de valores tiene ahora
estamos en una época gran tenemos que va
a salvar vida estamos en esa ventana de
oportunidades que tenemos además hay un
dato que le quiero y que me quiero
también proporcional estoy hablando de
40 millones de personas que están en el
nivel de crisis tenemos casi 20 millones
personas de personas que son 16 millones
de personas que están en la situación
también de estrés entonces todas las
personas que este año no estamos
atendiendo el año que viene vamos a
tener una situación que sería todavía
más no porque en
2019 teníamos 10 millones de personas
que necesitaban
ayuda en materia de alimentación este
año estamos a 40 estamos hemos jugado
inflado en tres años y la situación se
va a agravar si nos salvamos vidas y eso
es la primera la primera la primera
pista 2 y ahí le cobra también una pista
muy concreta que es que en esos
contextos en mali en níger y burkina
esos son países donde cada año se hace
una planificación que necesitamos
humanitarias que hay que atender y ahora
mismo hay muchos contextos donde ni el
20 por ciento de las necesidades
humanitarias están cubiertos y estamos
en junio entonces la capacidad de llegar
también a salvar vidas está bastante
limitada con ese nivel de financiación y
eso es lo primero y lo más urgente pero
por otro lado también tenemos que ver
cómo trabajamos en asegurarnos cómo
trabajamos en las causas estructurales
no porque mientras no trabajamos en la
cuestión de asegurar un acceso a los
servicios básicos a la salud
social que permite a esas personas
hay que profundizar en esa ocasión y
para eso estamos trabajando también con
los con los países en está en esa
dirección pero es verdad que para eso es
un trabajo que requiere la atención
política no sólo financiera para la
comunidad internacional